I don't know if you realize this but
there's this one protein that can raise
insulin
way more than white bread
way more than actual glucose that
protein is
whey protein so today let's discuss whey
protein and is it good is it bad what's
my thoughts on it what about can it
knock you out of ketosis so white bread
can increase the insulin by 87 percent
and if we compare that to whey protein
powder that can increase insulin by a
factor of 139 percent now normally when
we eat sugar okay the blood sugar goes
up and then insulin comes in there and
pushes it down but whey protein is not
sugar okay
it is amino acids then those amino acids
get absorbed very very quickly and so
they have an interesting fact because
they raise insulin but apparently they
don't spike your blood sugars in fact
there's been studies that show that if
you're eating whey protein after a meal
it can actually help lower your blood
sugars so potentially help a diabetic
now I don't know if that's true or not
but the point is if just think about it
if you're consuming something that
raises insulin it's going to then push
blood sugars down the other thing about
whey protein powder is that it also at
the same time when it increases insulin
it increases another opposing hormone
called glucagon which tends to kind of
neutralize some of the maybe a bad
effects of insulin I think a question
that people want to know is this would
whey protein knock me out of ketosis and
the answer is well yes because anything
that increases insulin will knock you
out of ketosis and then of course the
next question is will whey protein
powder increase weight gain well I don't
think it does because we're not
necessarily converting glucose into fat
what we are doing is we're increasing
insulin
which has believe it or not a lot of
positive benefits especially if someone
has insulin resistance in fact if you
take a look at all of the symptoms that
relate to insulin resistance
they're really a deficiency of insulin
why because with insulin resistance you
have the resistance and it takes greater
and greater amounts of insulin to create
the same effect so the question is will
whey protein powder create insulin
resistance well it's a little bit of a
mixed review because you know a lot of
times when people take whey protein
powder they also exercise at the same
time
exercise improves insulin resistance so
the jury is still out on that I do know
that whey protein powder does stimulate
muscle growth but it also at the same
time stimulates a lot of other things
because it actually creates a hormonal
effect on your body so it may stimulate
other organs not just your muscles like
the prostate for example there's also
been some data that it can protect the
liver
other data that says that it worsens the
liver it can create inflammation in the
liver increasing liver enzymes
especially if you take it without
exercising so
there's a bit of a mixed reviews on
exactly what it does and what it doesn't
do so would I recommend taking away
protein powder personally for me I don't
take it because I don't feel good on it
I also know that whey protein powder is
out of the natural milk complex so it
doesn't have the casein in it it doesn't
have any other nutrients in it versus
like if you had a fermented dairy like
cheese right it has everything in it
plus additional microbes so whey protein
powder is kind of considered like a
refined product but for some people it
can create some positive effects on
their muscles allowing amino acids to go
into the cells a little bit better maybe
after a workout but on the flip side you
have the whole egg and you also have
meat and you have fish which are a
better quality of amino acids plus you
get a lot of additional nutrients with
that plus you have less of an insulin
Spike but for certain people maybe in
competition with you know bodybuilding
um well they swear by it and it
apparently does help them so you might
just want to experiment for yourself and
see if it does help you and how you feel
after taking it but I wanted to give you
some additional data on whey protein
that you may have not heard before now
since we're on the topic of dairy okay
and let's say you're on the ketogenic
plan if you haven't seen this video you
should probably check it out I put it up
right here